in the darkness they're looking for
survivors the desperate who've managed
to make it to shore
people cast into the water when this
their overpacked boat was wrecked off
the Italian Coast migrants heading to
Europe but dying at sea
with daylight the Grim reality a growing
line of bodies a rising death toll
rough conditions meaning many including
children are already dead when they're
pulled from the water
the search and rescue operation is very
very difficult it's very windy and and
the sea is not it's dangerous so
um so it's that these operations are
really not so simple to to do at the
moment this reduces the possibility to
find other people still alive
the survivors are deeply traumatized
haunted by the horrors they've seen
people from Pakistan Somalia and
Afghanistan sailing from Turkey when
their boats smashed into reefs
while the living have been taken to
shelter for counseling the pope has
prayed for The Souls of the Dead
I heard with pain that a vessel has
broken apart in Calabria with many
people who have died many of whom are
children I pray for every one of them
The Rescuers keep searching but they
know the odds are against them
the Mediterranean Crossing is one of the
most dangerous in the world claiming
more than 17 000 lives since 2014.
Italy's right-wing prime minister won
power last year partly due to a pledge
to curb illegal migration and
trafficking she's repeated that promise
and expressed deep sorrow for the dead
as please search for the alleged
Smugglers involved
during the operations an alleged
Smuggler was also identified by a
carabinieri patrol and investigations
are currently underway to ascertain
responsibility for three other alleged
Smugglers also of Turkish nationality
who are currently on the Run
the search is ongoing
as the politics plays out here they must
deal with the Dead
the desperate who will continue to risk
it all at sea for new chances in Europe
Siobhan Robbins Sky News